good morning everyone I'm Eddie whoo I'm
a mathematics teacher at cherrybrook
Technology High School and welcome to
morning Matt with mr. Wu thanks so much
for tuning in today I hope we learn
something together and even have a
little bit of fun now I want to
acknowledge country right now I'm on a
dairy gland and Trevor technology high
school owes its existence to these
people who the traditional custodians in
the land have cared for this environment
over thousands of years and for all the
lands that you are tuning in from I hope
that you pay respect to the elders past
present and emerging who are the reason
why we can meet and live and learn on
these wonderful lands now today we're
going to be doing a bit of learning and
I want to say to all the parents out
there thanks for getting your kids
logged in you're going to need some
materials to do the learning today
you'll need some paper like you know a
spare sheet or a book something that you
can write and draw on and you'll also
need something to write with but as an
added bonus if you just got like a
pencil or a pen I'd love it if you could
try and get some different colors like
if you've got a colored pencil set or
even some markers anything you can use
to show some difference there if you do
have just a lead pencil we can make it
work I'll show you how later but we'll
come to that now what we're going to be
doing today is however you think about
how mathematics is all around us and I'm
going to give you one particular example
now I have something here I've ever prop
to help me illustrate this is a a map of
the world as you can see I pick this
particular one because well there's
actually lots of maths and you can see
on our I'm gonna bring it just a little
bit closer so you can see it a bit more
clearly it has all these different
countries on it and before I explain the
particular mess we're going to have a
think about here I'd love you at home to
talk to them as the next year if you've
got someone nearby and think about what
kind of maths
could you spot in a map like this we
could do so many different explorations
maybe you're thinking about world
population maybe you're thinking about
the area of these different countries I
think it's appropriate at a time like
this that we think globally everyone
around the world is in the same kind of
situation we are trying our best to be
responsible and stay healthy and well so
I think it's fitting that we have a look
at the entire world map here you can see
them move around the other side here
you've got kind of the American
continents over here now what is the
particular bit of maths that I want to
draw out of this map for you well it's
you might have had a bit of a clue
before when I told you the materials
that we needed for this lesson it's
something that you might not think is
very mathematical and that is color
there are lots of different colors on
this map I've seen lots of black and
white maps before and I'm sure you have
too and they're useful but color maps we
can see much more clearly because we can
tell the countries apart now let me
bring this even closer I'm gonna come
back round to this side if I show you
say here we go you can see Europe in
there hopefully it's it's big enough
that you can see it reasonably clearly
and if you have a closer look I want you
to see how many colors you can count on
this map and I really mean all of the
colors you can see for instance you know
the water here is in blue you can see
Norway in green Sweden in yellow Finland
in purple this is the Russian Federation
over here in this kind of salmon pink
color I'm counting something like one
two three four five six seven at least
seven colors maybe maybe one or two more
that I haven't spotted there at least
seven colors are on this map and I guess
that makes sense because there are
hundreds of countries on this map and we
want to make sure that we can tell them
all apart but my question to all of you
is how many colors do we actually need
to color this map did we need seven can
we actually do it with fewer now this is
where your materials are gonna come in
handy if you've got a blank piece of
paper there or a blank page in your
workbook underneath your heading I want
you to draw with me some imaginary maps
so if you are not very good like I am at
drawing like the exact things around
like I'm really terrible at drawing a
map of Australia because it's like a
weird funny awkward shape then don't
worry about that we're just going to do
some imaginary
Maps okay so firstly let's just kind of
like our um a big map that I was showing
you before let's just have a imaginary
map here that's going to include our
world okay now in our world I want us to
draw some imaginary countries with
imaginary borders now before we get too
crazy and complicated let's do a simple
one
to start with I'm gonna challenge you to
draw a map any map with just four lines
okay their names the straight lines they
can be Wiggly and all that kind of thing
but let's just use four to start with so
this doesn't go too complicated on us
too far so if I draw something like this
let's try this one line there's two
there's three and let me put in a fourth
one over here all right now you can
imagine this might be like what I did
when I showed you the map close up and I
held it close to the camera and this
might be a zoomed in portion of a map
and that's fine now my question to you
is how many different colors do we need
to color this map now we used four lines
right and maybe your mouth looks very
similar to mine or maybe it looks
completely different some of the cool
things about mathematics we can explore
all different kinds of situations in
this map I can count there are a
different number of well I guess we
could call them countries different
regions on the map that are separated by
borders
I'm counting let's do a count here I'll
use stay with a black yeah can I count
one up here two over here
three four and then five now there are
five sections on the maps so I guess I
could use five different colors one
color for each section and then they
were definitely all be different and we
wouldn't have any sections of the map
that are next to each other which are
the same color but it actually turns out
I don't need five different colors even
though there are five sections on the
map and I'll show you and I want you to
see if you can do this on your own piece
of paper as well let's pick a color like
say I've got red here okay if I take
let's do these in order I'll start at
the top over here if I take the first
section and color this in red I'm
just gonna do some lines like this so I
don't use too much ink here's my first
section now before I jump onto the
second one here I know it's got to be a
different color but before I do that I
notice that there are other sections on
the map that I could color with this
same color and still not have two
sections that are next to each other
which are identical right you can see
have a look on mine and perhaps on yours
you've got another section here I could
do either section three country three I
guess or country for I could do either
of them in red and I would still be okay
they won't be up against country one and
so everything would still look alright
so I'm going to do country number three
let's do that go okay so so far I've
already used one color to do two
different sections so I already know I
need less than five how much less than
five now if you are unable to find some
color pencils at home or color Texas
that's okay instead of using a new color
for the next thing maybe you want to
have lines that go in a different
direction or you could put dots or any
kind of pattern so you can distinguish
these sections from each other let's
keep on going around the map I'm up to
Section two now so here's my blue marker
I'm gonna do this in this direction over
this way now as I color this in and
perhaps as you look at your own map you
can see just like before there's another
section of the map that I could color
with the same color and still not have
it touching my country number two over
here which one is it well in this case
it's country number four right it
doesn't touch country number two so I
can use the same color and everything we
find let's color this guy in blue okay
fantastic now I've got one last section
to do and I can't do it in the same
colors that I've already used red and
blue because country number five it's a
bit unusual actually country number five
it touches every other country so
therefore I definitely have to use a
different color for it so thankfully I
orange marker here and I'm going to
color it in horizontal there like so and
hopefully you can see what I've got now
is a finished map I've used all of the
different colors that I needed but it
wasn't five it was only three and maybe
when you've had a go with your map as
well you can see that you didn't need as
many colors as you had countries you
could use fewer of them now it turns out
we actually never really need five
colors to do a map and we can prove this
I mean no matter how crazy you make your
map look let's uh let's do a more
complicated one now I'm drawn over here
okay I are I limited you to four lines
this time last time Radha
this time let's just go to town let's
put as many lines on there as we like
the only thing that I would suggest is
make sure that you actually make the
country's big enough to color okay
because otherwise this be very very
difficult for you to see whether it's
going to work okay let's have a go at
putting a bunch of crazy lines on here
so I'm gonna go I'll put one right
across the middle there one up down I'm
gonna put a country inside a country
that's a bit weird but it does happen
put one there another line here let's
put let's do something weird let's put a
bunch of countries here in a row put
another one there and then I'll put one
here which kind of touches that alright
now you may still be drawing your map
was totally fine take as much time as
you like this can go weird and crazy and
you can put lots of lines here I mean
you might think wow that is weird is
there ever a country inside another
country the answer is yes there are and
even if you're not doing countries you
can think a little more locally in
Australia we have the a CT if you're
from the Australian Capital Territory
hello and the a CT of course is
completely enclosed by New South Wales
so these kinds of things happen in that
all the time now as we have a look here
boy I should have checked this
beforehand there's so many different
regions I've lost count actually let's
have a quick look and see if we can do
this I've got one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
oh my gosh twelve countries how am I
going to color this now before we have a
go at coloring this I want you to notice
because unfortunately I can't see all of
the maps that you guys have been
creating but I can guess that some of
you willing have encountered this
problem as you go about coloring you
might start to use one color than
another one and then realize oh no I'm
starting to use lots and lots of
different colors here and you know maybe
there maybe I do need you know like
seven colors like I did on here well I'm
gonna show you we only need the number
of colors that I have here in my hand
I've got let me come a bit closer I've
got four markers here and in fact I even
II don't really even need all four
because I can use white as one of my
colors I'm gonna show you that we only
need four colors to do any crazy
different map
let me just demonstrate it on this one
okay now to work out which color to
start with out I should say which region
on which country to start with I'm
rather doing it like this and just going
one two three four five I'm actually
going to suggest you to look for a
particular kind of place I want you to
start with the kind of country that
touches the most other countries let me
say that again what you want to search
for is the country let's use a darker
color for writing some words there there
we go look for the country that touches
the most or the highest number of other
countries
sorry this is a bit messy now why would
we start with this hopefully you'll
start to realize why as we go now when I
have a look here I'm just doing this
very quickly I didn't plan this map or
anything like that so I'm guessing it's
going to be a country somewhere near the
middle right like country number five
you can see it's it touches one two
three four five six
different countries so that's a pretty
good candidate I'm down here this one
touches a lot as well but I don't think
it's as many 1 2 3 4 okay so I'm going
to start with number 5 so let's have a
go at this one like before I'll start
with red okay now once you've got this
guy colored in okay I again want to
suggest to you don't just do this in
random order let's see if there's any
other countries we can color with this
one before we have to give up okay which
ones can we do well apart from all those
ones that touch I can do the other
countries so long as they're not
watering this one let's start with
number one over here that landlocked one
that looked a bit like the AC T let's
color this one in I can use red there
okay that one's all good and you can see
I can continue this process I can keep
searching for countries that I can color
with this that's you know mean I can
still use red and minimize the number of
colors that I'm using so I'm going to
give you a second to do that while I
catch up and have it go over here and
while I do this and continue coloring
for all of the people at home who are a
little bit older perhaps you're in year
ten or year eleven or you twelve I want
you to think about does this sound like
a complicated bit of math does it look
very you know intricate and like a
difficult bit of calculus of
trigonometry does it look all that
complicated right but there's actually
some deep mathematics in here which will
reveal shortly all right now I'm
searching for my next one which touches
lots of other countries I said this one
touches one two three four this one
always some touches quite a few one two
three four five I can't let's do this
one six alright so hopefully you're
making some progress and my challenge to
you like I showed you before is see if
you can do this with just four colors or
fewer okay I can do that one which means
eight okay there we go
three is okay like so where else can I
go alright twelve that doesn't touch
anything
it's that and I think
I might be done for this color
I think that's finished okay let's use
green this time all right where am I
going to go okay now I think I think I'm
actually gonna go up here let's go to 11
and I'm being a bit sneaky like I said
before even though I do have a fourth
color here I've got an orange marker I'm
actually gonna use white as my final
color because what that means is at this
point I think I'm actually finished I
think I have done every little area here
and I've used as I mentioned before a
grand total of four colors now this is
not an accident
I didn't bring four white board markers
with me unintentionally I knew that I
could only use four colors and the
reason why is this wonderful piece of
maths called the four color theorem in
maths when we say theorem what we mean
is actually something that we have
proven to be true no matter which way
you try something you know you might
have heard of Pythagoras's theorem
that's to do with Wyatt angle triangles
and no matter what writing wood triangle
you have hypothesis theorem for the
parents in the room who are remembering
this kicking around in their memory a
squared plus B squared which are the two
shorter sides squared if you add them
together you get C squared no matter
what right angle triangle you start with
well the full color theorem it says that
no matter what map you start with you
could have a fairly simple one a
complicated one even one as crazy as our
actual world that we live in you only
need four colors and so I said before if
you are a bit older well what does this
have to do with some of the more
advanced mathematics that I've been
learning well if you're a year 11 or 12
student who studies mathematics standard
and there are several thousand of you
around New South Wales and there are
equivalent ones in different
jurisdictions then I want you to think
about a part of mathematics called
networks networks is a name for a part
of mathematics that is also called graph
theory and if you think about every map
that you've drawn as
network you can start to see this is a
graph theory problem this map over here
that we created for example are 1 2 3 4
5 I could say each country represents a
node on the map let's draw it up like
this 1 2 3 4 and then 5 and then I can
show the borders between the different
countries as the different links between
them as the different pods that I can
take through this network one for
example it connects to five one also
connects to and these are the only two
countries that have bought it so I can
finish with all of those different
branches there on top of look at two two
connects to one like I said it connects
to five and it connects to three three
I've already done the connection to two
it connects to five and also connects to
four four connects to five as well and
then that is all of its connections and
as you can see five connects to every
other one like we showed before and what
we're showing here is we can understand
all right so long as two vertices on
here two of the nodes are neighboring so
long as they have different colors we
will be able to create a map that's
equivalent to that because really all
these wiggly wobbly borders don't matter
it's just whether they share a
connection or not so as a bit of a
challenge for all of you I'd love you to
go away and dry and draw some more maps
and we know according to the four color
theorem you only need four colors no
matter what map you create but can you
create a map that requires just two
colors what about a map that creates
that you can create the requires exactly
three like this one over here have fun
with that
good luck exploring mathematics and have
a great day everyone stay safe at home
bye